Bonjour, nous sommes actuellement à Châlons
en Champagne pour passer les oraux du Capes
d'Histoire-géographie qui se déroulent dans
un lycée de cette charmante bourgade...
-Ah non mais je révise là, je passe mes
oraux demain et après demain, j'ai pas le
temps de tourner une vidéo!
-Mais on devait faire une vidéo sur «comment
devenir prof», c'est le moment rêvé!
On la fera quand alors?
-Plus tard!
-Dans ce cas...
Bonnes révisions et on va un peu accélérer
le temps...
Voilà! On peut commencer.
Dans cette vidéo nous allons comprendre comment
accéder aux métiers de l'enseignement, pour
ceux parmi vous qui l'envisageraient ou pour
votre culture générale, ou si vous êtes
jeunes et innocents pour savoir ce que vos
profs ont enduré pour arriver face à vous!
Commençons par les études!
Après le bac vous devrez tout d'abord obtenir
une licence, dans la matière de votre choix
et de préférence la matière que vous souhaiterez
enseigner, soyons logiques.
Vous ferez donc une licence d'histoire ou
de géo pour être prof d'histoire-géo, de
maths pour être prof de maths, de latin pour
être au chômage, etc.
Au terme de ces trois années de licence,
vous devez aussi obtenir un Master!
Pour cela vous est proposé le Master des
métiers de l'enseignement, de l'éducation
et de la formation, que ses amis appellent
master MEEF.
Il se fait en deux ans, hein, comme un Master,
et a pour but de vous préparer au métier
de prof ET au concours que vous allez devoir
passer.
SURTOUT au concours, en fait, parce qu'il
représente une telle quantité de travail
que ça sera votre principale préoccupation
durant votre première année de Master.
Et les suivantes, surtout en Histoire où
il est RARE d'avoir son Capes du premier coup.
La première année du Master MEEF consiste
donc en des cours et quelques stages d'observation
où vous serez amené si votre tuteur est
gentil à donner vos premiers vrais cours,
face à des élèves!
L'occasion de vous rendre compte que zut,
le cours que vous aviez préparé n'a duré
que 40mn et vous êtes comme un con sans rien
à dire face à vos élèves, ou encore diantre!
Le débat que je voulais lancer sur les médias
est aussi vivant que Michael Jackson.
Enfin, je crois.
A la fin de cette première année, vous passez
le Capes, et si vous avez de la chance, vous
passez en M2 où vous êtes déjà dans le
métier en fait.
Durant votre M2 vous alternez un mi-temps
et des temps de formation, donc vous bossez
tout en validant votre Master et à la fin
de cette année dite de titularisation, ça
y est.
Vous êtes PROF.
A vous les photocopieuses en panne et les
vacances à rallonge durant lesquelles VOUS
CORRIGEZ DES COPIES et préparez les cours
suivants.
Non mais.
Je ne pourrai pas dire grand chose de plus
sur ce Master MEEF parce que je ne l'ai pas
fait.
Hé hé.
Mais en gros, c'est comme ça que ça se passe.
Pour ma part j'ai fait un Master recherche
en Histoire, que j'ai résumé dans cette
formidable vidéo (lien vers les astrologues
de cour).
L'avantage de ce master, c'est qu'il me permet
aussi de passer le Capes sans devoir passer
par le master MEEF.
Parce que c'est quand même plus sympa de
déchiffrer des vieux documents aux archives
nationales que d'apprendre si oui ou non on
doit faire sortir un élève de sa salle s'il
a mordu son voisin.
Bon, ok, c'était pas ma motivation, je voulais
juste faire de la recherche à ce moment là.
Nous allons maintenant nous intéresser au
Capes à proprement parler.
Ce concours se déroule en deux séries d'épreuves:
des écrits, et des oraux.
Le concours portera donc à la fois sur l'Histoire
et la géographie, et vous aurez trois sujets
dans chacune de ces deux matières qui peuvent
tomber.
On connaît les sujets un an à l'avance,
voire plus comme la plupart des sujets restent
en place plusieurs années.
Pour cette édition 2016 les sujets d'Histoire
sont donc le monde romain de -70 à 73 après
Jésus-Christ, gouverner en Islam du Xe au
XVe siècle et citoyenneté, république,
démocratie de 1789 à 1899.
En géographie, il s'agit de l'Union Indienne,
des mers et océans et des mutations des systèmes
productifs en France.
Ce sont les sujets sur lesquels vous serez
interrogé aux écrits et pour l'un des deux
oraux.
Il vous faudra donc en apprendre le plus possible
dessus, voici donc ma précieuse liste de
conseils de révisions pour chaque sujet.
Par exemple pour citoyenneté, république
et démocratie au XIXe siècle, bah vous pouvez
commencer par 1789: les amants de la Bastille,
avec ça vous saurez sûrement tout de la
révolution française.
Puis après vous regardez Germinal, avec Renaud,
toujours debout, pour les mouvements ouvriers
toussa.
Vous trouverez pas ça dans le rapport du
jury hein, ce sont des conseils uniques que
je vous donne!
Pour l'Histoire Antique, je vous aurais bien
dit de regarder Spartacus parce que c'est
une série bien mais c'est un peu hors période.
Du coup, on regardera Rome.
Voilà, vous êtes prêts pour l'Antique.
Gouverner en Islam, eh bien, j'ai pas de conseil
à la con sur l'islam qui me vienne à l'esprit
en fait.
Désolé, va falloir ouvrir un manuel de concours
comme tout le monde.
Non mais.
Mais bon, on se rattrape avec la géographie!
Achetez vous un manuel de coloriage pour apprendre
à dessiner sans déborder, vous voilà cartographe.
Vous pourrez toujours bachoter l'Union Indienne
devant Slumdog Millionnaire (ou sinon plus
sérieusement y'a La Saison des Femmes qui
est sorti en mai et qui était vachement bien).
Râlez contre les mutations des systèmes
productifs en allant voir Merci Patron, quoi
de mieux que des fermetures d'usines dans
un ancien bassin industriel pour poser l'ambiance
dans votre copie?
Pour les Mers et Océans c'est un peu plus
délicat, alors notez bien ce qu'il vous faudra
retenir:
Pacifique, Atlantique, Indien, Arctique, Austral.
Voilà, c'est tout pour moi!
Plus sérieusement si vous préparez vraiment
le Capes d'histoire-géo je n'aurais pas assez
d'une vidéo pour vous expliquer tout ce qu'il
faut apprendre: connaître tous ces sujets,
lire le rapport du jury pour savoir le déroulement
des épreuves sur le bout des doigts, connaître
les programmes, l'historiographie et l'épistémologie,
la didactique, comment on fait un cours...
Bref, c'est pas mal de choses à retenir.
On va donc s'intéresser au déroulement des
épreuves maintenant:
Il y a deux épreuves écrites, de 5h chacune,
qui se déroulent dans votre académie.
Et en fait 5h ça passe trèèèès vite quand
on est dedans.
Sauf si on ne sait rien, sûrement.
La première est une composition tout ce qu'il
y a de plus classique, pour laquelle vous
recevrez un sujet portant sur l'un des six
thèmes à travailler et où vous devrez faire
une intro, un plan, une conclusion...
Rien de bien méchant.
Si cette épreuve est de la géo, vous aurez
en plus un fond de carte à compléter.
Là par exemple j'ai travaillé sur l'agriculture
en France.
Enjoy.
Pour varier les plaisirs, si vous êtes tombés
en Histoire le premier jour l'épreuve du
lendemain sera de la géographie! Et vice
VERSA.
La deuxième épreuve est donc un commentaire
de documents doublé d'une adaptation pédagogique,
on rentre dans du lourd.
Vous devrez donc analyser les documents, en
tirer les informations importantes, en faire
un commentaire de docs dans les règles de
l'art ET remplir une carte si c'est de la
géo.
Ah oui, et si c'est de la géo, il ne faut
pas non plus oublier de glisser des petits
croquis, des schémas, des tableaux dans votre
développement, ça prend un temps fou mais
les géographes adorent ça.
Toujours sur cette épreuve de 5h vous devez
réfléchir à ce que vous feriez si vous
deviez enseigner CE sujet à une classe, en
expliquant à quelle classe ça correspondrait,
par exemple si c'est un sujet sur l'Islam
c'est pour les 5e parce que c'est dans leur
programme...
Vous devez expliquer les notions que vous
tenterez d'apprendre aux élèves, comment
se déroulera votre cours, quels documents
vous utiliserez, ce que les élèves en retiendront
dans leur cahier, la marque du rétroprojecteur
que vous choisirez et la note que vous mettrez
au petit Enzo à la fin du cours.
Autant dire que vous devrez vous accrocher
pour finir cette épreuve en 5h, même si
je vous rassure: c'est possible, et que
votre poignet rendra l'âme et sera inutilisable
durant les deux semaines qui suivront.
Le chemin est périlleux.
Mais si vous réussissez cette épreuve, vous
accéderez au Saint Graal:
The Quest for the Holy Grail.
Les oraux!
Ce truc que l'autre est en train de réviser,
là.
-JE SUIS SUBJUGUEE PAR LE STRESS
-Pour ça vous devrez vous déplacer, du moins
pour l'Histoire-Géo, dans la charmante ville
de Châlons en Champagne qui voit tous ses
hôtels complets un mois dans l'année grâce
à moi, à nous, à vous.
Les oraux se déroulent sur trois jours:
le premier jour, plutôt tranquille, vous
êtes convoqué pour tirer au sort votre épreuve
numéro une: si c'est histoire, l'épreuve
2 sera de la géo et vice versa, on commence
à connaître.
Vous serez aussi autorisé à visiter la bibliothèque
pendant une heure et pas une minute de plus,
pour repérer les ouvrages sur lesquels vous
vous jetterez le lendemain pour préparer
votre oral.
Tous les coups seront permis, n'hésitez pas
à commencer par vous saisir d'un dictionnaire
ou d'un atlas pour assommer vos concurrents.
Par contre vous êtes limité à cinq livres,
donc reposez le avant de partir s'il ne vous
sert à rien et s'il reste des morceaux de
vos concurrents dessus.
Durant ce premier jour il ne se passe donc
pas grand chose, après la visite de la bibliothèque
s'il vous reste du temps vous pouvez aussi
vous inscrire pour assister aux oraux d'autres
personnes histoire de leur mettre BIEN la
pression.
N'hésitez pas à bâiller et à faire des
grimaces à chaque réponse que fournira le
candidat.
Le lendemain matin, c'est le grand jour, vous
tirez votre sujet de l'épreuve une, la mise
en situation professionnelle.
Encore une fois, il repose sur l'un des six
thèmes que vous avez dû réviser pendant
l'année.
Après un petit tour à la bibliothèque et
4h de préparation, c'est donc parti pour
30mn d'oraux qui comprennent un exposé plutôt
classique et une adaptation pédagogique:
comme pour les écrits, vous expliquez comment
vous feriez ça face à une classe.
-DANS LA DOULEUR.
-Vous aurez aussi 30mn de questions de la
part du jury.
Voilà.
La deuxième épreuve le lendemain s'appelle
analyse de situation professionnelle, et,
ce que je peux en dire, c'est que...
C'est compliqué.
Vous devez analyser des extraits de manuel
et d'articles scientifiques, en saisir les
enjeux historiographiques et épistémologiques,
et...
Je crois que si je rentre davantage dans les
détails je vais être confuse, moi-même.
En tout cas vous avez un dossier documentaire,
4h de préparation, et à nouveau 30mn de
passage suivies de 30mn de questions.
Et voilà, vous êtes libre!
-PARLE POUR TOI
-Et potentiellement bientôt prof!
Pour cela vous devrez attendre les résultats
début juillet, et si vous êtes admis vous
serez envoyé dans un collège ou un lycée
quelque part en France pour...
ÊTRE PROF ENFIN!
Rendez-vous la prochaine fois pour Les Pirates
2 reloaded the sequel come back.
Si vous voulez vraiment devenir prof et voulez
en savoir plus sur le déroulement du concours,
vous pouvez me poser des questions dans les
commentaires.